in 2014 a small craft called filet
landed on the surface of comet 67p
triumviracymenko in a mission destined
to make history
unfortunately things didn't quite go as
planned
when it touched down it was supposed to
be held by harpoons on the surface but
it didn't
these harpoons did not work and so it's
bounced
lawrence o'rourke led the team that
located the wayward lander
which had ended up stuck on its side
underneath a cliff this awkward position
meant that some of the intended
experiments didn't work for example the
drill
we know now that the drill didn't
penetrate the surface primarily because
it was
too high above the the surface itself
the filet lander provided the first
direct measurements of the comet surface
but because of the crash landing it
couldn't complete its full mission
and reveal the secrets of the comet's
icy interior
or so everyone thought now lawrence and
his team
have turned the crash to their advantage
by pouring through thousands of photos
of the comet's surface
with forensic precision and
reinterpreting data from filet's other
sensors
lawrence and his team have been able to
reconstruct what happened the day fillet
crashed
and in doing so got the first ever
glimpse inside
a comet
relay was lost for about two years well
i led the
lander search campaign to try to find an
image
filler on the surface of the commerce
but very close to the end of the mission
there was two images that came down
which struck me as being very very
unusual they showed what looked like ice
that had been sliced open it was
actually if somebody had got a chainsaw
or something that actually sliced
through the ice
laurence suspected that on its
accidental journey across the comet
filet had touched down on this
particular boulder scraping aside the
hard
dusty surface to reveal the bright ice
underneath
by combining thousands of photos into a
3d model of the comet's surface
the team managed to pinpoint the exact
location of the touchdown site
just 30 meters from filet's final
resting place
you can see on the left-hand side the
touchdown point which shows the
crevice between the two boulders now the
image being enhanced
primarily because we want to see philly
lander which is hidden the distance
underneath the cliff careful examination
of photos of the boulder
gave lawrence some clues as to how
exactly the lander had impacted the ice
the ice at the end of the the crevice
shows an impression of fillet in its
surface philly had actually
compressed the ice there and when we
look in
another image we could measure that this
depth was 25 centimeters
this 25 centimeter measurement would
turn out to be a vital piece of
information
now when you compress something you put
your foot for example in snow
then you gradually notice it gets harder
and harder and you can actually tell
with the time it takes you to compress
it it tells you the strength of that
snow
lawrence realized that they could use
this concept to calculate
the strength of the ice that filet
crashed into but they needed one more
piece of information
how long it took filet to compress that
25 centimeters
and that information came from an
unexpected source so the rosetta
spacecraft
has a number of different magnetometers
magnetic instruments on board which were
there to measure the magnetic field
around the comet
and the philly lander had its own
magnetometer but because villa was
crossing the surface of the comets
then the magnetic data it was generating
was changing
primarily because of the orientation of
failure it was rotating
it was flipping it was changing
direction the magnetometer was acting a
bit like a gyroscope
detecting every time filet moved or
changed direction
this meant lawrence and his team could
pinpoint the exact moment
that the lander crashed into the boulder
and compressed the ice
this graph contains the data from the
magnetometer instrument on the filet
lander and when we look at this area in
particular you can see
spikes and this duration this spike is
three seconds
and we know therefore that took three
seconds to compress
the ice calculating the compressive
strength revealed that the interior of
the boulder
was incredibly soft the ice is softer
than the freshly fallen snow
it's softer than the foam that you find
on the
seashore when you're walking on seashore
it's softer than the
the froth that you find on top of your
cup of your cappuccino this incredibly
soft interior had been hidden inside a
hard outer crust
filet's crash landing meant that its
drill couldn't sample the inner material
but the landers haphazard journey across
the comet
provided an unexpected peak below the
surface
fillet has in fact excavated the the ice
it's actually
broken the top covering of the dust
which was covering it
and exposed something that was hidden
inside for billions of years
and so you're seeing really the the
interior of a comet that has not been
exposed
since its formation when filet crash
landed
six years ago it looked like some parts
of its mission would never be completed
now thanks to some ingenious detective
work lawrence and his team have
uncovered the first ever glimpse
inside a comet and helped the philae
lander
make one final contribution to cometary
science